[Music]
so that's the logic behind that specific
type of music
i've achieved everything i got the cars
i got the girls i got the
clothes i got the mansions jets probably
got
like popping bottles you know i got it
all and
yet there's still a void i mean i was
basically drunk to church every sunday
morning hated every bit of it
you know trying to get to you know get
you to speak in tongues and all kinds
and my guitar cost twice as much as my
car
wow i had two amps in my bathroom alone
i
alaikum ingredients of peace how you
guys doing subscribe if you haven't
already hit that notification bell my
next guest
he went from being the guy who was
screaming ah you know the
heavy metal guitarist and then he was
also
being dragged along from a young age
going into church
he hit a breaking point he was like man
i don't believe any of this stuff
became an atheist and then what can i
tell you next
you're gonna have to watch the show
because he's on the dean's show don't go
anywhere
so how are you doing brother joshua
you're coming in all the way from
where where are you at nashville
tennessee man
are they called the good old boys man i
don't know what they call it down here
it's fitting down here yeah yeah yeah
tell us what's the situation with
everything that's erupting now
down in uh that's like a red state right
yeah i believe so man i mean actually to
be honest which man for the most part
um things are normal i guess
you know as normal as they can be you
know i'm able to practice my dean
uh wear a throwback in public my
whiteboard in the cob
we don't get harassed we don't get you
know ostracized or anything like that
man we're good yeah good luck
well that's for people that i don't know
who are who are tuning in they heard me
say red state this is like
how they've got us things divided right
you got blue red
green uh i'm sorry uh blue is like red
and blue but democrats green
right i mean but we know islam just
brings all humanity together you know
under the worship of the
of the one and only created heavens and
earth being morally upright
following the way of all the messages
and the prophets and messengers now you
yourself
you actually you so you were born in uh
in
tennessee no sir i'm actually from
wisconsin
wisconsin okay closer to us over here
we're neighbors yeah i was born yeah i
have a lot of family in
chicago how long have you been there in
um
in uh tennessee now so half my life 15
years in wisconsin
the other half of my life tennessee i'm
30 right now so 15 and 15 man
yeah yeah so so i mean just like
bringing us up like how
because that's more of a conservative
you know uh tennessee is more
conservative right republican
conservative right that's what we mean
so how how uh what what's the the
feeling the client
the climate down there with everything
that's going on have you followed some
of the events that's happening with
trump
and all that for sure i mean honestly
man i think that um the media shows one
aspect
yeah you know they have their own agenda
and then you have the day-to-day
conversations with everyday people right
you have the conversations in the gym
conversations in the grocery store
conversations with your
relatives right and no one has ever
personally attacked me in all praises
for a lot ever like i have
i talk to people all the time in the gym
grocery store again they see me they
know i'm muslim i actually
make salah in the squat rack you know
i'm making fidget spinners yeah
mashallah and um they all they do they
just go
you know hey man what are you reading
i'll be like oh i'm in the quran or i'm
reading
you know and other they're just curious
man but nobody has ever
like called me terrorist call me mojave
you call me this attacked me why do you
believe in
blowing people up that's that's the
media showing all that stuff man but
when you have these everyday
conversations
it's nothing but just good old
conversations man
yeah everyone's very nice and kind
i mean you have some of the uh some of
the nicest people who come from la
desert you know
from the south hospitality man right
southern hospitality
but i would you say that many have also
become
victim of the hate machine and the hate
the hate uh propaganda
you know from the media and people with
you know an agenda
and then they have this uh this fear you
know of the unknown
yeah um but at the same time like you
know i discussed this a lot man
you know this isn't this isn't something
new or specific to the muslims
right this is something that's been
going on for a very long time it was
with the african americans
during the civil rights movement with
japan during
you know uh whatever world war one world
two um
native americans all these different
things man they're always trying to be
that us first them
right us versus them mentality and
trying to you know just scare people man
control them for their own agenda man so
at the end of the day it's like it
doesn't
people pick up on it eventually and they
go
oh man you know african americans
they're not different than us or native
americans or japanese or whatever
and they people pick up on it like okay
dude we're tired of that story and then
the
media moves on to me i'm just like
they're gonna
bleed this thing out and to the point
where people are actually like dude we
know muslims all right muslims ain't
like this
that's a specific selective group of
people and the media is going to move on
man you know
so yeah how did you perceive islam in
muslims before you
actually became a muslim great question
um so actually man
the only thing i knew was what the media
told me right that was the only thing i
knew because i didn't know any muslims
right but at the same time i knew i was
22 and i accepted islam i've been
listening eight years i'm good
for that um and uh
i i knew that again then the media the
news
they have their own their own agenda man
so but that's all i knew that's all i
had to work on you know i was here in
tennessee
and they were talking about at the time
eight years ago oh muslims are going to
hijack the school buses
you know the high school buses the
elementary buses and they're going to
blow them up
right that's what was saying that that
was at the time and i'm like
all i could do was like i want to see
some muslims try something like that
let's do you know saying but that's all
i
had to work with man you know because i
didn't know anybody at the time
so it would work to answer your question
it wasn't a very good perspective but at
the same time i was kind of
neutral in the sense that i didn't
accept that narrative
but i didn't have anything else to work
with either
so how far after that and this whole
school bus thing what
this was something that was coming from
the media exactly yeah yeah it was
just the media man just saying you know
and that was the buzz you know all my
family are like oh my god you're here
josh did you hear
the time i've blown up the buses they're
going to hijack the buses you know the
buses that i'm riding they go to high
school right
you know at the time and i'm like so i'm
kind of having to back my mind this kind
of sense of uh
fear or um uncertainty is that really
going to happen is that really going to
take place man
what is going on here who are these
muslims man what what are they about why
would they do something like that
yeah do you kind of see like a similar
thing happening
today you have like again blue red black
white
you know all of these divisions big
divisions that are happening here
in america what do you think about that
yeah it's again it's it's i feel like if
you if you have the everyday
conversations man
no one brings those topics up you know
i'm saying no one's really afraid of
those things but it's the media man the
us
thing where it's you know black lives
matter blue lives matter
muslims are you know trying to blow this
up this that and the other man
the way i look at him and it's just
they're just trying to instill fear
anyway
man but yeah it's not reality
so now how far after that you know the
the school bus situation how far after
that
did you actually get exposed to a muslim
or to islam
um a few years man so that was right
around probably
16 17 man something like that in high
school
and i didn't accept islam until i was
22. and the reason why i said the
slamming brief
is because i met a muslim man actually
muslim
talked with them and at the time i was i
don't know how much you know about my
backstory eddie but
i was a heavy metal guitar player man
like long hair don't care
you know long hair don't care i like
long hair
you know you switched it here
switched you got yeah mashallah long
hair don't care me
so it's like into metallica and stuff
like that
i mean the whole nine yards man and my
guitar cost twice as much as my car
i had two amps in my bathroom alone like
i'm a
committed man and um so wait again you
were
just uh let's stop there don't lose your
place so you were you were you were um
a guitarist in the band yes sir yep yeah
did you also did you also do vocals and
sing
um you know i was you know screaming
man you know so that that's a little
different than like is that kind of like
uh bring us
like we hear these name kid rock you
have kit you have kiss what group of uh
music is that in heavy metal
just have a that's just that yelling
screaming right yeah
that's a lot of what's the point that
what's the point there uh man it was
just a vehicle
for um trying to express your aggression
and the frustrations that everybody has
you know we all have even as muslims man
we have things that we're going through
we have frustrations
um we have these emotions that we're
trying to you know get a hand
kind of real a little bit and it was
just misguided man
it was just frustration as a child
growing up not knowing my dad
you know i didn't meet my dad till a
month uh
before i accepted a slam i see
okay so that's the logic behind that
specific type of music
is it like just screaming is like
attacking somebody being violent you
know what i mean
taking your frustrations on other people
it was just a means of expressing myself
in a way that i thought was not harmful
to anyone
you know i think that's why that was my
approach
is is it also like in many of the uh
much of the music it's just like you
know the
uh degrading of women talking about
money
talking about you know country music is
more like i lost my house my car my dogs
stuff like that
but how about this yeah yeah but what
about like this uh this
uh metallica music what's the message in
there like what are they
again it depends man every every band
had their own approach their own agenda
their own
mission their own statements man but in
general man it was just
talking about the frustrations of life
really but does it all is there is it
whether it's
drug abuse alcohol abuse uh child abuse
you know trauma all these different
things you know
that people experience either
themselves or you have you have a close
relative who's an alcoholic or a drug
you know
it touches everybody right death from
diseases and all these different things
so that was just kind of
uh that we would talk about man again
don't lose your place but this is very
interesting so you at what age did you
learn how to play the
did you play any other instruments or
just mainly guitar
man uh so i picked up the guitar at 15
man 15.
i was like i literally you couldn't tell
me the color of my wall man because
my wall was just plastered with posters
of every single musician
vocalist bass player drummer couldn't
tell me the color of my wall man not
just
15 years old i was like i'm gonna be the
greatest guitar player that ever lived
and for the next
eight years that's what i did with my
life every single moment that i had
so who were at that time like the the
most
popular uh heavy metal bands is kiss was
kiss
considered heavy you know they're iconic
man you know definitely iconic man but
at the time for the stuff that i was
into manual
heavy metal thrash metal it had its peak
its heyday in the 80s and 90s and you
know i'm talking about you know this is
only eight years ago so
this is 2000s where gangster rap and all
that stuff was like you know i'm on the
charts man so
in general you know again bands that
probably no one's going to know your
audience probably going to listen to is
lama god gojira
trivium these bands that probably no
one's ever heard of man but those were
the bands like
they would be like the equivalent of
metallica in the 80s and 90s man
so metallica came later yeah metallic is
from
early like late 70s uh 80s
yeah yeah yeah what about the what about
that famous very famous
uh was he also a singer yeah he was a
singer
was he what kind of music was uh was it
um
is it chris cubane or the one who yeah
yeah
um nirvana from nirvana
and i believe audio slave and um some
other different uh chris cornell what's
up
chris cornell is that nirvana was a
group nirvana that was audio
and kurt cobain is from nirvana but
chris
my memory serves me correctly that's his
name he's the one that hung himself
just recently i believe so i thank you
what was his what was his name chris
chris what chris chris cornell so he
committed
suicide yeah man you know he um you have
that you have um
you have uh i'm thinking there's a
singer from lincoln park
he committed suicide man um they're yeah
they're you know there's a number of
different ones but even like robin
williams and all these different people
yes because
you know and i think it just because you
know when you hit a certain pinnacle of
success in the dunya right in the in
this worldly life when you hit a certain
pinnacle of success
you literally money is no option man you
can have whatever you want
literally within the snap your fingers
you got it vip treatment right this way
sir you know i mean
and you don't have anything after that
and then it's just like well
i guess it's just downhill from here
because you've reached the pinnacle of
quote unquote success man
it's really hard to grasp that
especially if you've reached the
pinnacle of success
and you still don't feel fulfilled
you're like dude what else is there
i i've achieved everything i got the
cars
i got the girls i got the clothes i got
the mansions
jets private yachts popping bottles you
know i got it
all and yet there's still a void
yeah you know what i mean yeah the the
question is why and then that one also
for
nirvana yeah he he also he did he commit
suicide what was
what happened with him controversial
there was him or his
uh his wife at the time but uh basically
uh
he was killed via a shotgun sharkman
yeah
all right so let's say uh all these
others that we're talking about like
these people
are some of the most uh famous
influential
musicians and i mean yeah you know like
that
they reached the pinnacle of what their
dream was
yeah you are not just on some small
little circuits
and you know no one knows their name
their name is global
yeah don't you think about that like
it's not like when you start practicing
like you you did
you know islam and and then it's like oh
man my iman is so great today i'm gonna
commit suicide like it doesn't it's like
when you're in islam you know when yeah
right
it's like you got contentment you got
peace solace you get
it's all the ingredients for you know a
happy life
right so tell me now what happens
uh when you met this uh you said you
finally met a muslim yeah
yeah but my story man my story is uh you
know i praise the law
um allah azzawajal is all-knowing all
wise
how powerful man and um allah knows us
better than we know our own selves
and he guides whom he wills how he wills
my story isn't the most romantic story
or exotic story
um i didn't read a book i didn't do i
wanted to marry a muslim
i was a heavy metal guitar player i met
a muslim woman
and i was like what do i have to do to
marry you i want to be with you
she said you got to become muslim i said
how difficult is that
thinking i'm still going to be a male
guitar player i'm still going to
you know do everything that i do but i'm
gonna say i'm a muslim as well man
and after some time i accepted islam
and within a week right i don't i didn't
even have the imam
i didn't even i didn't know nothing
about salah zakat
some uh the pillars of iman i didn't
know
jack dude and i about a week into
saying i'm a muslim in fact i called the
the imam
the local imam down the street the night
before and i said i'm looking for the e
man hey i hope you guys are enjoying
this weeb's episode don't forget
subscribe right now if you haven't
already hit that like button so
we can get more people engaged and we
can reach more people
and support us on our patreon page
subscribe right now
peace salaam alaikum you know eman like
the faith in our heart
yeah i'm looking for a man are you the
man
you know i didn't know nothing dude and
um after about a week
i actually started looking into what
islam had to say about
kohid about who issa really was
um all these different uh fundamental
beliefs of islam
and it blew my mind like if you've ever
seen looney tunes
back in the day when the jaw drops on
the floor
like that was basically what happened to
me i was like i can't believe what i'm
hearing right now
because this is what i believed
my entire life because basically i
considered myself if someone asked me at
the time
what are you i said i'm an atheist i'm
an atheist
because i didn't see anything that
represented what i believe god was
you know so you were you were you're an
atheist
at that time yeah yeah so before that
were you christian
or did you end up i was raised man you
know
um i was raised to be a christian and my
mom you know my entire family to this
day i've been most of my years my entire
family dad and mom's side
no one's muslim but me man only one yeah
yeah
and uh so yeah i mean i was basically
drugged to church every sunday morning
hated every bit of it
you know trying to get to you know get
you to speak in tongues and all kinds of
stuff man but by the edge of like 11 or
12 man i just like
i was like dude i just i don't believe
none of this man yeah
what were the what were some of the
things that uh stood out that you
remember that you're like no i can't dig
this this doesn't make sense
to be honest you made no offense to
anybody but i mean i'm just answering
the question man one of the things so i
went to a specific church i don't even
know what it's called
like what that specific sect or group or
whatever you want to call it
um where they literally fall on the
floor and they're like compulsive like
they're
like looking like they're having a
seizure yeah like the first time i seen
that i remember being like a little kid
and being like call 9-1-1
and i'm like dude i have a seizure man
you know and it's like when you're
speaking in tongues and doing all these
things i'm like
this is so strange man like this can't
be
god and the most crucial important point
is the belief about isolation about
jesus
i couldn't accept that god's a man that
god died on a cross
that god was a one time he was a baby
infant because you know i have a
three-year-old son
i see how dependent he is on his mother
and myself
dude can't do nothing for himself you
know what i mean he had a i've changed
his poopy diaper
you know i gotta he's gotta be breastfed
at the time you know when he was first
born
he can't feed him he can't do nothing
i'm like that's the creator of the
heavens and the earth
sorry but i can't accept that man you
know
wow so then how long after that did you
consider yourself an atheist
from uh until i was uh accepted slam at
2010 yeah so then
you're i guess what i would say like so
there's also some things
why i why i would say i was an atheist
and that was because i was angry at a
lot
because i seen so much war so much fitna
so much people using religion for their
own agendas
all these different things all this you
know rape and murder and all these you
know pillaging and
evil stuff in the world i'm like god
doesn't care about us man
you don't care about us you know and
that was my mentality at the time and
that's why
deep down i guess you would say i was an
agnostic i believed in god i believed in
love but i was so
angry because i didn't understand the
wisdom behind all these different things
i didn't understand all of it at the
time
that i said you know what i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna reject them
you know i mean thinking that you know
that actually means something right at
the time
and then uh start start uh yelling
in the uh
yes right with the frustration huh then
you got an outlet here right
exactly yeah so uh wow
so you were really uh what was your goal
at the end you wanted to be a star
you wanted to be a rock star played you
know
packed arenas man like like some italian
man i wanted i wanted to make metallica
open up for me
i wanted them to open up man that was
the dream huh the main
you know but you know i just had i've
always had super high ambitions man
since day one so yeah yeah for sure man
so now you come into islam at that time
was your attention it was just purely
for
you got um married
you know yeah yes i just wanted to get
married man i wanted to continue living
my life
and i told her i was like i'll become
muslim but
i hope you're cool with me touring the
world because i'm going to be on the
road all the time i'm going to be in the
studio i'm going to be traveling
i'm going to be doing this and doing
that you know and she was like
and she's not my current wife you know
things didn't work out and that's
because you know
we what we did was haram you know you
know i shouldn't have been talking to
her she's been talking to me
but like i said if if allah would have
chosen a brother
a man to say these same exact words and
have the same exact approach
i would not have listened i would have
been like that's cool bro
you want to be a muslim that's cool but
i'm a metalhead guitar player dude
so you do what you do you and i'm going
to do me
but the only way to open up my eyes
my ears my heart my mind
was to fall in love with this lady fall
in love with this sister
to just for me to open up and actually
lend my ear to what islam has to say and
then as soon as i did
as i said that's history done
i believe man you man just penetrated my
heart
you know i do bow hunting you know i'm
archery as well like i'm looking at my
boat right now
i mean it penetrated me in the money
yeah
you know and i'm the love man i'll
praise it for allah
masha'allah what would you i had this
interesting uh
story a true story i met someone who
asked me the guy asked me are you muslim
and i told him uh what do you mean i
said uh depends on your definition of
muslim because you know a lot of people
they
think muslim and all these negative
connotations that come with him so i'd
like to
define the word if you mean by muslim
one who
xyz you know submits his will to the
creator of the heavens and earth et
cetera et cetera
yes but then he actually came out and
said oh i'm muslim
and it was a polish gentleman but then i
was like oh you're muslim
and then uh he opened up the
conversation he goes yeah i married a
muslim
girl and i married i turned muslim to
marry her
and i was like okay did i just stop
there he goes
because he goes he's also he says he's
an atheist so i'm like
hold on there's a contradiction there
right but it's it's similar to your
story but then i was tell i would start
talking to him and
you know it's like uh god almighty allah
put
us to cross paths but this was very very
interesting and similar because
she also she's not really practicing
but she held on to that she wanted to
respect her parents wishes i guess
her parents are practicing so then they
ended up
they're married to this day but he's
stuck in between like two worlds the
world of unbelief
but then when you talk to a person like
that you know the foundation of the
atheism is
so weak right there's nothing there and
then when you explain the truth it's
like
you know wow the truth it just stands
out clear it's lucid
yeah so what would you tell someone like
that who's in a similar who's
in a similar situation but the person is
not engaging with really with islam he's
not really
engaging you know so he's stuck in the
uh
on the other side of the fence but he's
saying he's muslim but it's kind of uh
it's hypocrisy because it's kind of
fake yeah right weird situation man
i mean at the end of the day man you
have to actually ponder man
you know there's many different avenues
of many different ways man you can read
the quran you can read the hadith and
you can look at your own self you can
look at the sky you can look
at the universe allah has made all of
this for us to ponder man you know and
at the end of the day
like dude chao
order does not come from chaos
when i clean my house my three-year-old
toddler
immediately destroys it it's like he is
anti-clean it's like something in him i
must destroy the whole house it cannot
be organized right so it's like
you know they talk about the big bang
right this big bang theory it's like
there is so much order in the universe
man it is so
perfect now that it's okay it's 50 50
there's
some tweaks that need to be made here
and there you need to you know you know
that you have some maintenance everyone
no 101 percent
perfect every single day
that doesn't come from chaos it's just a
big explosion you know
an awesome boom you have order that
that goes that goes against common basic
intellect man
it doesn't take a rocket scientist
figure that out yeah
we usually tell people they just if
they're genuine and sincere
when you started to engage with the
koran with islam
i mean as opposed to when you because
you did some engaging obviously when
you're going to church on sundays with
the bible like what was the
the difference here yeah i mean again
and did you look at other religions did
you look at other religions
for sure man but at the end of the day
man toheed
makes absolute sense and the fact that
it is defined that define that for us
for people for for
sorry to cut you up for people just
never heard this word so what
what do you mean by that yes the unique
oneness of allah the one the unique
oneness of god almighty of the creator
of the heavens and the earth
okay the pure monotheism there is
oneness in worshiping him
oneness in his ability to do things that
nobody else can do
right worship like this is what tohi
this is what the oneness of allah is
and islam has literally cut off every
single path
avenue valley whatever you want to call
it streetway to get to anyone other than
the law
it is so detailed and intricate no
matter how much you if you sit down and
reflect and ponder and say maybe i can
worship someone other than
you know a lot of this way or this way
islam has
cut off every avenue it is so intricate
and detailed it's mind-boggling
but at the same time it's not because
you know it's from a law right
um so that stood out but sold me man
this is like
there's no worship except the one that
you're intending to worship man
yeah that's that's that's uh really uh
something that
like you said it stands out from every
man-made ism
man-made religion you know the pure
monotheism
if this was from anyone other than allah
the quran you would find
many contradictions man
yeah so did you find any
not yet man's been eight years not even
so you so you really put it to the test
i mean obviously to have you come this
far
and this is my this is my salvation this
dude you know here's the thing man
i didn't leave music i haven't played a
guitar i haven't touched guitar
in eight years right since i accepted
this slam i love guitar to this day it's
something that's never left my heart
right i don't listen to music i don't
play guitar i don't do any of those
things anymore
but that's still in my heart man um
what was i gonna go there sorry i had a
brain fart for a second uh
one sec you talking about the music
i left it because you know
it's for a lot man you know at the end
of the day like i left those things
because it's for a lot dude it's not
that i don't love it
you know it's that i'm submitting to my
creator man you know
yeah when you look at the wisdom also
it's beautiful because you see like
obviously you know so
you can give an example like you know
the the musical instruments and all that
it's like the the male uh malware
that you know the virus is carried in
right
and so the the music opens you up and
we're not talking about you know um
the chirping of birds and the natural
sounds and that we're talking
specifically here these
uh wind and string instruments and the
stuff that's
the message that's conveyed in this
music
so now when this malware when it gets
into the computer
right now the virus destructs spreads
it controls in your whole perspective of
life so now when these when these
messages
yeah situation that happens in your life
you're going to be weighing that
against that malware that you're talking
about right
yeah so when that's when those messages
you know a lot of those subliminal
messages a lot of those messages that
come in
from many of the music that's out there
i mean it it doesn't really do good for
the heart and mind doesn't it
yeah this that and the other man it's
constantly the magazines the billboards
yeah smackdown yeah
so when we explain this i mean uh
because many people they go to sleep to
music
uh to hip-hop to to to metal to
all sorts of songs and they get up to it
and it's just their whole life
they're kind of asleep to the reality of
like what's the purpose why am i here
right so this weakens the heart and many
people uh when you explain it the wisdom
behind it and they say oh that
that makes sense right uh so you you you
got that so you
started to um change your life
alhamdulillah
man that was i mean that was my dream
though you know i mean that was my
absolute dream man
um to play music and be a famous guitar
player man but
at the end of the day man it it's meant
to walked out now you know we here and
we obey you know
yeah and we and we look at it as like um
you know what's the end goal here
right you said it talking about purpose
and what's the angle why give it up
you know because you said is there any
contradictions right i'm looking for
contradictions that was my point like in
the sense that
this is my salvation and this is my life
i didn't give up music because i hate it
right so if if islam is wrong if slams
contradictory
if islam is not the truth i'm going back
to music dude
yeah i didn't give that up because i
hate it i would gladly go back to music
man but
there is no contradictions in this line
man it is so accurate man it's so
precise dude
it's unbelievable man the more you look
into it what do you advise for people
who are out there when they say
okay but they see a lot of because
there's a big
movement you know there's big money made
in bashing islam so it's a big industry
people get out there and they they uh
try to uh
say oh here's a contradiction uh here's
one here's this and they bring up all of
this
all of this stuff that's out there have
you uh
have did you battle in the beginning
with some of that because
here's what they do i don't know if
you've heard of the term astral turfing
have you heard of the term astral
turfing
this is this is yeah i think i couldn't
give you the definition but i think i'm
familiar with yeah
what happens is a lot of companies like
pharmaceutical companies they do this
and other
industries what happens is when one
piece of truth is put out there okay
and now you have enemies to the truth
you'll have ghost writers
so people start writing you know
articles against the truth
even though the truth stands as the
truth so now
there's so much confusion put out there
so you have like they'll flood
the internet they'll flood you know
they'll flood like right so
so they'll flood the internet with 50 60
100 different articles so the average
person is like
well confused and lost but there's that
one out there
that is 100 percent of truth but now
they'll have their own
doctors scientists write off on these
things
and this is called one of the ways of
astroturfing so we see this also with
islam we see the same thing we see that
the truth is out there but then you have
enemies to the truth and then people get
confused
because of you know a lot of these uh
false articles and videos and
that people put out there have you been
experienced some of this
yeah man but i think there's three
important points man um
that someone needs to do in order to
find the truth first and foremost you
need a bag of law
right you need to ask allah your creator
guide me got me to the truth
allow me to see the truth and to accept
the truth you need to use your own brain
man
you have to you have to use your own
intellect and think about and ponder
what is being said here right you need
to be able to do
things on your own and thirdly when you
want to learn about something man
who like if i wanted to learn tennis
right i want to learn tennis as an
example
am i going to go to a rugby player and
be like hey dude teach me tennis
you would look at me like a [ __ ] like
i'm not a tennis expert dude i'm
a rugby professional right so who are
you getting your information from what
are your resources man
if you're going to someone who is not a
muslim
first and foremost they're not a muslim
they openly say and declare i disbelieve
i'm not a muslim
and they're all they're doing is
attacking and bashing islam
is that who you want to take your
information about a religion from
or do you want to go to the people who
are authentic who are actually
have you know their resources and they
explain to you
this looks like a contradiction but in
reality it's not
or this this was abrogated you think
it's a contradiction
but actually that was abrogated a long
time ago you know
and we can harmonize these different
hadiths and these different things again
you know exactly right you're going who
is your source dude you know what i mean
if you want to learn about islam go to a
muslim don't go to someone who has
nothing to do with islam and doesn't
know islam doesn't practice islam
you know what i mean very very good
point you you don't go to uh
learn about black history to to the kkk
right
you don't go to learn about you're gonna
be like look yeah in the bible it says
such and they're gonna have an
interpretation
and their own agenda they're going to
see black people are inferior look at
them right there you know
yeah and you don't go you don't go to
the communist professor to learn about
god
so i like that point what you're saying
you got you got to go to the right
sources and from there pray directly to
the creator of the heavens and earth
and yeah and and use some critical
thinking skills and god almighty if
you're sincere he will definitely guide
you like he guided you
so what what what were what were so that
was the number one thing i liked what
you said the pure
monotheism and i like it was so it's
it's been
so uh embedded in you now that you've
developed a certainty this joaquin
that we call it that you're at the gym
and you're stopping to pray
nothing's stopping i hit my set of
squats
and i make my salah man that makes a jew
you know and no one bothers me man
i'm just like i just do my i don't
explain myself i don't get hey man i
might do something kind of weird to you
guys
i just say i love you not to do my thing
man
yeah you find it what do you you just
find a little area and you just go ahead
it's time to pray and you're just
doing the squat rack man i literally
re-wrecked my set
and i shot life right so you what do you
say to muslims a lot of muslims who just
kind of like you know
got negligent abandon the prayer it's
kind of disheartening to see what do you
somebody who
uh coming from what the background you
came from what advice do you do
you gotta get in the seahawk man you
gotta get him to see how man you gotta
you gotta be wise with the dough you
know you gotta be wise just remind them
man and like look dude at the end of the
day man
the first thing that the that the the
servants of god the servants of the law
man is going to be questioned about is
the salah man
and if everything if that slaw is on
point come to life everything else is
gonna be on point in charlotte and if
not
ask me a tough tough day for you man and
i'm like dude it is literally
you have 24 hours in the day 24 hours a
day man if you get your eight hours of
sleep and you work your 10 hour shift
and you
you know whatever you do all these extra
you know little errands here and there
you ain't got 25 minutes on totality to
offer five
five pairs a day dude literally you
ain't got that
you got the ability to see hear think
taste touch you got nice kids you got a
beautiful wife you got a beautiful
husband you got a nice job
you got a working car you got roof over
your head you got all these blessings
that you cannot enumerate
and you can't even offer something as
simple and as basic as making salah dude
come on now very important things to
think about
so evidence-based it wasn't just an
emotional decision because you'll see
people
they say i had a dream like why did you
start following this way of life oh
because so-and-so came to me in a dream
this happened like like what for you it
was like
the the message of of the simple message
of worshiping the creator not the
creation
and what what other thing would you say
that stood out like
justice like honestly man um
when i found out that just because
you say i'm a muslim you say the
kelliman to tohit right the the shahada
right
the testimony that i believe in allah
and i believe that muhammad
sallam is the messenger of allah that
does not make you
ineligible to go to the fire well yeah
that doesn't just because you say that
dude don't mean that you can't go to the
fire
and i was like i've never heard that in
my entire life man that most people it's
like what
i say i believe it's done that's all i
gotta do kick my feet up and
just wait until i get to you know right
this way mr angel right in paradise
right it ain't like that man
you say it and then you gotta act man
you gotta move dude
and if you don't i mean again
that doesn't make you ineligible that
you could go the fire now you
eventually inshallah god willing you'll
be removed man
but the justice of just because you say
you believe man don't mean jack dude
like
you gotta put some effort and some
action behind that statement man
so that justice of that man really like
stood out to me man
one one of those things that reminds me
just saying some negative derogatory
thing about jesus peace be upon him can
land you
a ticket in the hell fire you know
denying jesus peace be upon him is one
of the mightiest messengers you can i
can land you a ticket right to the
hellfire
you know one way pass man yeah so so
when you when you now
when you go back you engage with uh
because there's a lot of christians in
tennessee right
whole family the whole family when you
engage with your family you talk about
you know
uh look i'm muslim i'm one who submits
to god to the will of god like jesus you
know
when you talk about you know a chapter
named after his blessed mother in the
quran when you talk about somebody
struck we believe
you know he was the messiah the word of
god when you talk about all of these
similarities commonalities and us
actually probably be more conservative
than a conservative in many aspects
closer than anybody man yeah like you
action and statement and everything man
so when you when you engage like that
like what do what do those people's jaws
drop i mean what what kind of reaction
do you get
when you share some of these uh yeah
sadness sometimes
uh hearts closed you know before you
know
um yeah i don't want to hear it let's
change topics like the same subjects
you know you ain't gonna convert me you
know awful things man
yeah yeah yeah a bit sad but um we keep
we keep striving inshaallah allah opens
i mean
it was something that really i struggled
with for a long time through man you
know because
you know i've been listening muslim
eight years man and again eight years of
you know trying to be a good
practicing muslim i'm saying perfect by
any means man but just trying to be a
good practicing muslim man and
eight years later like dang ain't nobody
in my family except the slam you know
and then i started thinking about like
well dude
who is clear and more articulate in the
message than the messengers
who could articulate the message better
than the messengers and yet we know on
yom kiyama on the day of judgment
they're giving messages and profits i
got
zero followers man so it kind of gives
me a little bit of solace you know
we still try and still strive for things
like that but at the end of the day
you know a lot of guys wills man yeah so
from singing
in the metallic band or actually from
playing the guitar in the metallic band
to now accepting islam reading the quran
there's a particular
surah chapter in the quran that muslims
recite
17 times a day it's the opening can you
let them hear this
can you let them hear it coming from you
then please you want me to recite man
yes please put me on the spot all right
no promise
[Music]
this is because some people this might
be the only chance that they ever have
to actually hear
the quran now coming from an american
coming from a former christian
coming from my right neck he's actually
this is the
this is one of the proofs is one of the
miracles you know just to hear someone
like you reciting the
the verbatim word of god almighty uh
allah and in there this chapter
is praising god almighty uh you know to
the best way that can be praised i want
i want to thank you very much you know
for spending some time with us
if you're uh you plan on visiting uh
wisconsin uh
area anytime soon in the future it's
winter bro i ain't trying to get out
there right now judy i'm crazy
man so when it when the weather comes up
uh hit us up if you're going to be in
that area close by we like we'd like to
hook up with you uh maybe in person we
can have you in the studio we can
continue
continue talking um can i mention
something really quick
absolutely yes go ahead okay um so for
your viewers and for your followers man
i'm your audience
um i do run a youtube channel called
project dreams achieve it alhamdulillah
it's for all things mindset marriage and
the muslim struggle
and especially the revert struggle right
a lot of us men we put a lot of effort
into
calling people to islam unfortunately at
least in my town in my city
there's not as much effort in actually
helping people remain muslim and
nurturing them as muslims man so my
channel is dedicated to
all things mindset marriage and that
muslim struggle al hamdulillah you can
find me a project dream achievement man
and i want to say thank you
so much from the bottom of my heart
brother i dude it's so crazy man
i watched you eight years ago when i
accepted this lamb
and i watched your uh you know i bought
your dvd about your journey to you know
how you became a muslim
and i'm like man i'm going to ask this
brother what's your favorite move are
you do you like the darsh choke do you
like the ankle pick do you like the
rear naked choke because i'm all about
jiu jitsu and martial arts man so
i wanted to ask you what your favorite
move is before we go oh mashallah so you
usually i like to mount and finish with
the x choke
from the bottom the move khabib did i
like to put the triangle also
is that something um yeah so you have
this
different guard type stuff uh this is uh
the triangle from when you're
playing the guard right like that move
that i don't know if you
saw the last fight with khabib yeah he
went for he went
he went yeah he went for the arm lock
but he switched to the triangle yes
yeah so this yeah masha allah this is
great
very nice brother i'm very uh elated to
have met
you and talk with you hopefully we can
we can ensure i'll meet meet in person
and have you
on the program again
i got you man we gotta hook up then we
got that date
inshallah sometime in the future soon
inshallah thank you brother all right
may allah preserve you protect you and
grant you the best the best in this life
in the hereafter
and that was joshua angel here in the
dean show sharing his story
very great points that he talked about
one of them no matter where you're at
and it's time to make sajdah
time to make salat makes a lot and think
more than you've been told
about islam you've been fed a lot of the
misinformation so do what he did engage
with it
and you're like our friend who i share
with that polish guy
or that italian guy whoever you just
married someone just because
what because their parents told you to
go ahead and you had to be muslim
don't do that don't don't practice
hypocrisy you know stand for what you
believe and i can tell you just like he
did
he engaged with islam submission to the
creator not the creation
he looked at the evidence and the thing
that pointed
him even further into going to the truth
it stood out was that pure monotheism to
to heed
and be sincere cry to your creator ask
the one who created you say guide me
guide me guide me
guide me why am i here what's the
purpose of my life
what's it all about i'm gonna die soon
it's gonna be finished
islam has all the answers islam is the
complete blueprint for life
and this is just another incredible
story
from the many that we've had and it's a
testimony
to this beautiful way of life being the
truth based on proof and evidence
so what do you got to lose at the end
time is ticking we're about to leave
this life
and now you either get it right now
because once the test is over
it's finished you can't go back and
change your grade
f means flunk and
and it's a hot place that people are
going to end up the hellfire and we
don't want to
end up in the hellfire we want to end up
in jannah paradise so i've talked enough
and it behooves you
to look into this dean looking to islam
and with that said
again subscribe if you haven't already
and hit that notification bell and
support us on our patreon page thank you
for tuning in to the new show we'll see
you next time
peace be with you assalamu alaikum and
if you like this episode of tading show
like this video share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now